[Music]
[Music]
this guy's
been around he's throwing bags on the
floor now listen up
boy i said throw the money in the
flatbed
try to get clever again and old boy is
getting a face
just do what he says
get in the truck next time you blind
sorry pal
it's his son his only son
i need to know who's responsible i
killed my son
we've deployed large amounts of time
money and effort
in the search for justice not good
enough it's got to be an inside job
you're going to have to go undercover
there's an armed truck driver
we have a new addition may i introduce h
cash trucks can be dangerous
[Music]
they're serious leave this to me
who is this [ __ ] lunatic did you work
for
suck my [ __ ] dick what did you say
i said we need a different approach to
us
it's not any of the usual suspects what
do you want me to do
i can do in two weeks you know what i
wish you could do in 20 years
you're going to give me a knife i need a
face
we need to understand what's yours
[Music]
if it's not a cop what is he
he's a dark [ __ ] spirit
[Music]
you